chris hogan here i spent a lot of time
traveling speaking and talking with
people all around the country a topic
that continues to get me fired up is the
self-made millionaire and their success
story
I've even devoted segments of my
podcasts retire inspired to talking with
these self-made millionaires you're
about to step into the life of someone
who crossed over to millionaire status
on their own terms we just don't do that
it's bondage so we will have no part of
it you don't want to miss it people this
is millionaire first off we never set
out to be millionaires what we set out
to do was get debt-free and you know I
listen to the Dave Ramsey show when I'm
quilting that's one of my hobbies and I
hear people who get out of debt early
sort of the way my husband and I did and
Dave always said you're going to be
millionaires and I'm sure he's right in
every case because it's just a natural
thing you have the habits now of good
money management
and you can't help but involve into a
millionaire it's like a child that just
keeps growing they can't help it I'm
Julie and I live outside of Cincinnati
and whether northern suburbs I am
married my husband's name is Mark he
can't be with us today because he has an
international job and he's in China
right now I have never made the income
that you would expect a millionaire to
have in fact it was not my income or my
husband's income we just plowed money
into investments and what really made us
a millionaire is that the stock market
took off in a big way the real estate
market also took off and at the time I
became a millionaire my house was
probably worth about a hundred thirty
hundred forty because the value of my
assets
it was my assets that made me wealthy
not my income
to put it all in a nutshell because this
was a process it took us a total of
about seven maybe seven and a half years
between deciding we wanted no debt to
becoming a millionaire
we were millionaires by the time we were
37 I've been a millionaire now for over
20 years actually it was kind of
shocking to us truthfully I didn't
believe I was a millionaire I had some
extreme poverty when I was in high
school and this is a little hard to talk
about my my father was very ill and he
lost his job frankly we lived on welfare
for a period of time and there were four
separate times that I came within 24
hours of being homeless so I I learned
to be terrified of debts I also learned
that anything can happen to anybody I
have to say initially the lack of money
was part of my identity it took me a
long time to get over the fright that I
would ever become homeless this had a
huge impact on me when I was young so I
had
it was it was a scarcity mentality many
times people feel that it's unbelievable
that you can have a very average income
and not only get out of debt but become
a millionaire when my husband and I
started we were making somewhere between
40 to 50 K for the majority of paying
off our house but you start looking at
money as a tool that you use and not
part of your story and it's not me it's
an asset that the Lord has given me to
use being able to give is the very best
part of having wealth
first off paws is a no kill animal
adoption center it's just north of here
in Monroe Ohio and I have been a
volunteer with paws
probably for 25 years now it has
bothered me that there was a mortgage on
the shelter again I'm very afraid of
mortgages and debt having come close to
homelessness in nine months my husband
and I have paid off four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars so that pause has
no mortgage people are probably saying
what's your income I don't even have an
income where all this money came from is
the stock market there's again there's
been a big run up in the stock market in
the last nine months my net worth has
has come up eight hundred and eighty
thousand dollars I've given away four
hundred fifty K so the pause had no debt
the rest of it you know Here I am I'm
giving money away and I'm richer than
I've ever been
I'm not afraid of homelessness anymore
but I know other people are and so some
of the ministries that we want to
support are some of the local ministries
that support the homeless in Cincinnati
such as the broken bus ministry but we
have plans to help other ministries in a
big way just the way that we've made the
impact on paws
for anybody who want thinks they want to
become a millionaire
but it looks so far off what I would
tell them is concentrate on getting out
of debts because you can never be
wealthy if you're in bondage and that's
basically what it is but the truth is if
you work hard enough to get out of debt
you have the skills that will make you a
millionaire
from start to finish it took my husband
and I about seven seven and a half years
I have a friend who was a single mom she
did it in ten years it really doesn't
matter how long it takes once you get
out of debt you will evolve into a
millionaire because now you have
millionaire knowledge and you have
millionaire habits you can't help it
you will become a millionaire
[Music]